joining me today is a trial lawyer
focusing on civil criminal and
constitutional law and according to his
Twitter bio he's America's most
successful political gambler Robert
Barnes welcome to the Rubin report happy
to be here I am glad to have you here
because you sir are smack dab in the
middle of a million things that I'm
thinking about all the time so I'm glad
we're doing this before we do anything
related to civil criminal constitutional
or any other kind of law political
gambler what are we talking about there
I know what we're talking about but tell
the people sure I started doing when I
was really young so the I used to bet
friends and other people with elections
and then started doing it became sort of
legal loosely in 2004 so I started
betting on presidential elections and
was sort of a side hobby until the Trump
election and Trump I thought this was a
very money-making opportunity the
British betting markets are now much
bigger than they ever used to be so I
could bet as much money as I possibly
could and in and basically dug in much
deeper than I had before so I've sort of
been around politics but hadn't done in
deep for maybe you know 20 years or so I
mean I've been very active but then it
become inactive it becomes skeptical the
political process and decided well I
should really dig in and as part of this
I discovered this whole emerging
movement in a cross-section of areas and
what was happening ideologically so I
became involved for other political and
legal reasons along the way it was sorta
like a scott adams win big league where
you get the six there somewhere exactly
there you go exactly where you get like
six degrees of separation you're trying
to learn this you end up learning four
or five other things in the process and
so I went to the Republican National
Convention the Democratic National
Convention traveled across the country
talked to tons of people dug into what
was happening the social media space the
reddit space the Twitter space I didn't
know what Twitter was until then really
I knew but some Earth Day it was a
happier time exactly it was and from
YouTube was still YouTube you know who
wasn't censor to so the I was uh you
know involved and invested in it went
over to the UK placed a lot of big bets
they thought I was nuts when I was doing
it they're like how Trump's not gonna
get elected that was the sort of
consensus so much so that one of the big
books
paddy power actually was paying out
Hillary Clinton bats before the election
Jesus so if you'd bet on Hillary Clinton
with Paddy Power they acted like you had
already won and paid you out are they
still in business they are so business
though they took a huge hit on the
election after they'd taken a big hit on
brexit which I've been on before that
and then after that had bet on various
European elections so it was just
understanding how the electorate works
I'm a sports bettor as well and being
able to predict and forecast elections
was fun and it was a way to just make
extra money and in the process ended up
having this whole life experience that
was fun and entertaining and very
profitable can I ask you what kind of
profits we're talking about how about
half a million dollars very nice if I
could admit if I could have bet more I
would have bet more yeah there was only
limits as an American you only have
access to the individual betting shops
you can't get onto the bet fair and the
bet trade and markets if I could I could
have made seven figures where they use
it would have been nice jeez all right
well there's a lot to talk about there
but but I really want to focus on some
of the legal stuff because we chatted a
little bit in the greenroom I'm starting
to think as much as much I obviously am
a free speech guy and we're going to
talk all about the First Amendment all
sorts of things that the way the world
is going right now with the platforms
and with the trolls and with the
anonymous accounts and with the targeted
harassment and with the way that we see
media members attacking kids which
you're very intimately involved with and
a whole bunch of others have I'm
starting to think we really need some
legal answers to some of these problems
which is really against my default
position as a person in terms of speech
and that's exactly why I wanted to have
you here so before we get to all that
just tell me a little bit about your
legal history when did you even get
interested in law and what sort of made
you say alright I'm gonna be a lawyer
lawyers are that well like I'm gonna be
one exactly well you know I've always
liked underdog representation and that's
sort of what my legal practice is and
that goes back home as a kid my favorite
TV show is the equalizer as always the
odds and and to represent people against
even if I'm representing someone that's
famous are well-known they're stacked up
against someone that has more
institutional power wealth or the US
government behind it and so as a kid I
like shows like Matlock and Perry Mason
and that was part of it and and you
you'd see lawyers as being integral to
the process of making meaningful change
and particularly to stand up for people
who couldn't stand up for themselves and
use our legal system and legal rights to
accomplish achieve those objectives and
so that's why the law always appealed to
me it didn't appeal to me from a
money-making perspective though I've
been very you know had been lucky in
that regard it appealed to me and then
appeared to appeal to me on a status
basis it appealed to me is I can make a
difference for little people people like
my father who spoke out his whole life
and theirs in Austin was punished for it
and the there's the old biblical proverb
that says the sins of the father will be
visited on the son I always say well the
sins against the father are long
remembered by the son and so he was
mistreated and now treated because he
stood up not for himself but for other
people in a wide range of environments
and I just wanted to equalize the
playing field if I could and was he a
lawyer also no he wasn't he was he was
an accountant but it wasn't a certified
public accountant so the he went through
all the craziness that it was my first
experience with the credentialing
Society here my father was a very
skilled and gifted accountant but
because he wasn't a certified public
accountant he'd grown up in an era where
that wasn't necessary he couldn't get
the kind of jobs that other people could
do and so he was often both
overqualified at under qualified for
employment and then he had a habit of
standing up for people who are being
maltreated or mistreated in his work
environment or other environment which
led to him he end up being a newspaper
delivery guy so when I was a little kid
we he was delivering newspapers throwing
him outside the other door we did a
morning around and afternoon around and
then he end up doing inventory work so
he just picked up whatever blue-collar
work he could so even though his
education and his intellectual
capabilities far exceeded what he could
get economically it was a product or a
side effect of the credentialing society
and the ability of more powerful people
to take advantage and misuse and abuse
that power against less powerful people
like himself Wow
so all right so let's flash forward a
little bit to what was maybe one or two
of the cases that kind of got you got
you sort of on the map so that now
you've become one of the sort of I think
one of the central legal figures in the
the free speech battle so I started out
doing all kinds of free speech
representation represented victims of
domestic violence was suing big banks
before anybody was suing big banks and
subprime lending was I'd clerked for a
Native American tribe I'd clerk for a
big corporate law firm I'd clerked for a
street lawyer I always say if anybody
wants to learn legal education just read
all john grisham's
you'll get a good sense about the legal
practice really works and worked for a
big high-profile plaintiff's lawyer and
finally got to a space where I could do
the kind of cases I wanted to do and I
liked First Amendment cases and that
happened to parallel to areas of law one
was civil where I was representing Ralph
Nader he went on TV and said look I'm
getting bombarded I have no lawyers left
to help me if somebody can please reach
out I was like sure I'll take the case
so there was I remember we did the case
in Arizona was me Ralph Nader and like
12 lawyers kept coming in I kept
wondering when the door was good another
lawyer came another you had the
Democratic Party Republican Party both
aligned to prevent his access to the
ballot deny people the right to
circulate petitions for the cause or
candidate of their choice and so I took
that case and it took four years a lot
of litigation a lot of fighting but
ultimately we got one of the most
important precedents in the country out
of the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals
it's now one of the most cited cases in
the country that protects the right to
circulate petitions the rights of speech
in the context of elections the right to
choose who you want on the ballot the
right of third parties and independent
candidates to access the ballot in a
weird way though even though just by the
fact that it took four years isn't that
part of the problem right there cuz yes
four years later it's like he doesn't
necessarily have the energy to run again
or her sight movement kind of moves on
to something else etcetera it was like
the beginning of law fair of its own
time politically motivated ideological
law fair to exclude independent and
dissident voices from being able to
meaningfully participate in the
political process and the main goal and
objective is to silence the audience to
not allow the audience to hear or choose
or participate in the way they want to
choose they don't get to choose their
news they don't get to choose their
views that's what the censorship
campaigns were about and that crossed
over into representing people who are
accused of being tax protesters and
these were people had very distinct
political views about the way the tax
laws were operating they were mostly
upfront about it with the IRS I mean how
many people you know write letters
saying I'm not gonna pay taxes and
here's why mostly these were
libertarians basically right it's never
somebody that hates the tax system
because they want to be taxed more right
that's never happened precisely and it's
people being open and honest about
they're not trying to cheat anybody that
I'm trying to defraud anybody and you
have Supreme Court it said 20 years ago
in a case called cheek versus the United
States they were not supposed to put
people in prison for having different
beliefs about the tax laws especially
given this is a country that was founded
on people who had very unique beliefs
about the tax
so I end up representing Wesley Snipes
in that context I'd also represented him
previously when he'd been falsely
accused of parenting a child in New York
where they were abusing the family court
system to invade his privacy to lie and
libel him and basically because of his
celebrity used his celebrity to make
themselves notorious so we brought a
unique civil rights case and that
context had one got them to fold and
capitulate he hired me then to represent
him in the criminal case on a whole
bunch of tax charges and it of acquitted
of all the felony fraud conspiracy
charges and even half the misdemeanor
charges on cases like that I'm always
curious when it's a high-profile rich
celebrity and it's tax related I always
think it's like these people a guy like
Wesley Snipes movie star you know he's
worth millions and millions of dollars
the idea that he would and I don't know
the specifics so please correct me if
I'm wrong but the idea that he would
know every specific thing that his
accountant was doing all the time seems
crazy to me like he's running a business
where he's mostly probably focused on
acting and traveling and everything else
and it's like the idea that unless he
instructed the guy to do something
illegal that you'd end up in jail
because of something like that seems
pretty bananas to me completely because
what happened with him is he had one
accountant advisor that he started to
distrust so I think this guy's up to
something on on real estate deals and
other deals it turned out he was
completely right he was trying to tell
the New York authorities four years
before the guy end up getting busted and
he had this guy was involved with Tom
Brokaw he was representing a whole
roster of high-profile celebrities
turned out he was embezzling from them
and mass he had abandoned his wife for a
stripper long story so the this kind of
going to jail for a long time but but
Snipes was like hey there's a problem
here nobody would listen and that led
him to turn to other professionals and
they said you know what if you have any
questions we'll go right to the
government and get your answers he was
like well that's got to be no problem
they're gonna talk to the government
they'll figure out what it is no way
that's how this unfolded that's how this
whole thing unfolded it was in fact they
even tried to delete and destroy all of
his letters and correspondence in
communications and luckily they were he
had separately backed them up if he
hadn't we wouldn't have been able to
prove how much he had communicated
directly to them he even asked to be
audited he said come in and audit me and
then come back and tell me what is it I
owe and why it is I owe it and how does
the legal system work and this is
someone rooted in the
frickin American and Native American
tradition who has a long history the law
is not being applied the way they're
supposed to be on the books so the idea
that maybe the law is not being applied
the way it's supposed to be wasn't
foreign to him Native American tribes
whose tribal agreements are still not
being enforced you have African
Americans between 1865 and 1955 of the
United States like his parents like his
grandparents who said the law in the
book said they had the right to
participate in the political process the
right to be on the jury the right to run
for office and yet that wasn't happening
in reality so the idea that there was
some mismatch here made sense to him and
he just wanted he's a well school right
to the government and I'm Wesley Snipes
I have a little bit of attention don't
forget sir my questions at least and
then everything will get resolved that's
why the jury was shocked by the case
this was a very conservative jury the
lead jury foreman was a guy who had been
a long time corrections officer in
upstate New York
they deliberately manipulated the jury
pool they picked it was literally an
all-white jury pool so there was a joke
that it was as the only thing more white
than the snowfall from the Green Bay
Packer in New York the day before was
the very pool in this nice case but nine
of the 12 jurors who are honest and got
onto the jury said they didn't think he
should be convicted of anything there
are three jurors who were holdouts who
said we want to convict him of things
and we came in with the admitted they
came in with a bias before they became
part of the jury so on the misdemeanors
they did a split verdict they said well
we'll convict him on these three
misdemeanors even though we don't think
he's guilty of him because that will be
no problem they didn't know there'd be a
wacky sentence because there was shocked
at the outcome of the case so how much
of law is just that just the public
attention stuff manipulating the media I
don't have to name I could probably name
a zillion lawyers that seem like they're
far more interested in Fame for
themselves than doing the right thing
and just managing optics rather than
getting to just what is right precisely
that's what it often is I mean you're
seeing it now in the Roger stone case
where there's an obsession with
silencing it and all the people on the
media on the left that talked about free
speech and talk about the ability to
protect yourself and our criminal
justice system has problems are suddenly
muted when here is you have a judge
spending all this time saying maybe we
shouldn't allow him to publish a book
how has that become part of American
criminal justice process so the
effectively at often is defending
person in the court of public opinion
because often what the government is
doing is using people as sin goats using
people as sacrificial lambs using people
to coerce public opinion often not
really rooted in the facts of a case not
really rooted in the law of the case
targeting people solely because of their
celebrity or their fame and then you
have lawyers who often look at a case
and they don't look at the case about
how do I win the case they look at how
do I get the most press coverage how do
I get the most media coverage and they
often deserve their clients in that
context so it's critically important
especially in high-profile cases to put
the client first and to manage the court
of public opinion at the same time yeah
and that cannot be easy especially in a
day of social media and look at the fact
you're here talking so it's not like
you're not like a totally private person
no and yet you want to do what's right
by your clients and exactly so like in
Snipes case the I think the odds going
back to huh it wasn't up to the odds of
he was convicted of the top felony fraud
counts was 8 to 1 so there was a day
said there was only about a 10 11
percent chance of him being acquitted
you had see you know people on CNN
saying that he had no chance to win some
are still prominent legal commentary now
how do we always have legal comment
commentary people on CNN often but all
the cable networks who get everything
wrong and they keep bringing them back
it's like their political what precisely
and these are people that have mostly
never practiced law never tried a case
never dealt with a real case and and
it's amazing they'll just they're there
they have a law degree but they often
don't have any legal experience and
they're really there for for political
purposes they know if they say the right
thing that their media boss doesn't want
them to say they'll get rewarded even if
what they're saying is complete and
utter nonsense yeah so one of the things
that I've been saying over the last
couple years and and you know I'm a free
speech guy is that right now I'm more
concerned that we're silencing ourselves
then the government is coming for our
speech at this very moment now of course
I understand the government can always
come for our speech and there are many
ways that you're laying out right there
that they can through going through the
IRS or whatever else but I'm more
concerned right now about sort of the
mob mentality the way we're weaponizing
the
and social media and the rest of it so
let's just start with the big question
right now social media are these
publishers or platforms right now
Twitter Facebook YouTube and can you
explain the difference between the
absolutely so all of these big tech
platforms originally we're able to
obtain their monopoly status two ways
first they got Congress to pass special
immunity laws loosely called section 230
the particular section of the laws that
applies that says we're going to presume
that everything you do is as a platform
and not as a publisher and consequently
you'll be immune from any lawsuit as a
publisher as long as you are acting as a
platform so meaning that you're just the
you're just the space so to speak people
can put all kinds of crap up on there
you can decide what you take down or
leave up but you're not endorsing it
exactly you're just a public venue your
your the the venue where they're coming
to organize the Republican Party on the
election night right you're the
restaurant you're the there you're the
convention center that's all you are and
then that was even additionally
privately promised by people like Jack
at Twitter who said I'll be the free
speech wing of the free speech party so
he induces people to participate induces
people to become part of Twitter and to
give them in a competitive economic edge
against their then competitors on the
grounds that hey look one the law only
applies if were a platform not a
publisher secondly we are promising you
we will protect your free speech rights
in your free speech liberties now it's
important in that context free speech
means the right to not be stopped for
your speech their right not to be
harassed for your speech the right not
to be censored for your speech it's both
that's why my style for a free speech is
not just the right of expression it
means I have a rights that someone can't
target me because of my expression and
use elicit mechanisms they can question
my ideas they can attack my ideas if I'm
a public figure they have limited space
in which they can talk about me as a
person but what they can't do is invade
my privacy what they can't do is follow
me down the street what they can't do is
put a billboard outside my home these
are things they can't do so is that a to
me that's a really fascinating change on
the way things have happened because if
I was to look at just generally what's
going on on Twitter these days it if I
was to walk down the street right now
somebody just everyday was waiting
outside my house and started screaming
at me and all sorts of things there's
legal recourse I could take right I can
file a what can I do if it's not a civil
suit and get an order of protection
against like people like I did a lot of
work back in the day when I was a young
lawyer for victims of domestic violence
and we were part of the beginning of the
orders of protection that got instituted
for them but it's not limited to the
domestic violence context it's anybody
who's stalking anybody who's harassing
anybody who's invading your privacy you
have an equitable right and a legal
right to bring legal action against them
and have the courts say I'm gonna stop
you from doing this and if you violate
this you're gonna be responsible for
legal fees you're gonna be responsible
for cost I can even put a statutory
amount on there and they often do
they'll say every time you violate this
it's a thousand dollars it's five
thousand ten thousand whatever is
necessary to deter those laws exist
already there so are those laws are
there any laws related to that that
exists in the digital space now again I
want to be very clean when we're doing
this because so for example all day long
trolls are jumping on me
go [ __ ] yourself well you know just the
word it's far worse than that usually
but I guess the worst kind of things all
day long same accounts I block on my
mutant they just make new accounts over
and over and over okay it's not the
worst thing in the world I'm still here
I'm alive it's okay right but doing it
in the digital realm I think people
would see that very differently than
stalking someone just outside of their
house or in the realm of reality it is
only to a certain degree the same laws
apply so it doesn't matter whether it's
the digital world or the physical world
the same stalking laws apply the same
harassing laws apply so somebody who
stalks can be sued somebody who stalks
they can even be charged with crimes
under particular cases so they can be
referred for criminal prosecution that's
happened to people that have done that
to Mike certain of it for example so the
so you can use civil remedies you can
request criminal remedies with criminal
referrals you can bring equitable
actions you can bring legal actions and
the courts are actually very sensitive
to it particularly like in California
where because of the problem of stalker
Otzi they expanded the kind of
protection either in the digital space
or the personal space and the US Supreme
Court is increasingly recognized that
these days those spaces are
indistinguishable so it's interesting to
me because as part of let's say the free
speech cruel online right now I'm very
president of a lot of this stuff because
it's like I want everyone to be able to
express themselves and yet I understand
we need certain super specific laws
libel laws slander laws harassment laws
and yet there's a certain irony where
it's like the free speech crew are the
ones that are gonna have to defend those
laws it's like a really weird place for
people like us to be and I think I agree
the way I think of it as I see it as an
unequal equation so what's happening is
you're seeing big media big powerful
forces people with big platforms be able
to defame little people that will be
able to run smear campaigns against
people it will be able to attack and
encourage stalking and harassment and
and online mobs that will and not be
held responsible and it's the little guy
that's still fighting for their free
speech and yet they're the ones the
little guy who's getting sued by big
institutional actors are backed by big
institutional players and they're being
sued for defamation they're being sued
for libel they're being sued for their
being the platformed and so we need to
do is equalize that playing field
because the First Amendment is also
about protecting everybody speech and
that means the little guy can't get
harassed in ways the big guy is immune
from and the big guy can't use powers
that the little guy doesn't have access
to so it needs to be equalized out so
true free speech means people who are
important in the independent press and
the freedom of press of the independent
press not be harassed not be not the
legal system not be used against them
disproportionately indiscriminately not
have the D platforming happening against
them disproportionately indiscriminately
and that's what's taking place and
that's what needs to equalize so true
free speech means we need to have some
equality of treatment between everybody
okay so now backing that to the platform
verse publisher part of this so they
they help get these law what statute did
you say to a section 230 section 230
okay so they they help get these laws
passed now they're treated as platforms
but it seems that they're acting often
more as publishers right
they now admit that so in other suits
that I've brought against Twitter they
said that they are a publisher and they
want all of the protections as a
publisher they want all the legal
privileges of a publisher because a
publisher has a wide range of special
protections particularly if it's has any
institutional form or backing so there's
certain libel laws that apply to
individuals differently than they apply
to corporations
the same is true of big media publishers
so they're now saying to courts so in
the Praeger suit against YouTube YouTube
in Google's defense is we're acting as a
censor we're acting as an editor we're
acting as a publisher and look at all
these privileges we have as a as a
publisher which a lot of people it was
one of the issues we raised was if
they're acting as a publisher they
shouldn't have the immunities of a
platform mm-hmm unfortunately the courts
have interpreted what Congress sent to
them in a political way this is often
the case with a lot of law a lot of laws
that interpret it through a political
framework and how they interpreted it as
oh the court as Congress doesn't want us
to allow big tech to be sued so we're
gonna give them all the protections as a
publisher and all the section 230
immunities as a platform so they have a
degree of protection as Senator Holly
described it a degree of immunity and
benefits that no publisher in the world
has that Congress is the one that
actually gave it to them as the courts
have construed it though some would
argue that's beyond what Congress
intended
right so Prager lost the initial lawsuit
correct are they and I know Dennis but I
actually don't know the answer it's are
they pursuing other legal measures that
you're still trying to go through the
appellate process but they're unlikely
to prevail under the current environment
because the current environment is such
that like the when I pursued Twitter I
brought unique novel theories I brought
breach of contract theories consumer
protection act theories because my
equitable theories because my view was
Twitter had lied to people to induce
their participation profited from that
participation sold that persons like a
someone like Charles Johnson would come
in and thirty thousand other people join
Twitter to follow Charles Johnson they
now have all of their private
information they get to aggregate that
information and then market eyes it and
monetize it and then they get to censor
and ban Charles Johnson forever from
Twitter because they don't like one
tweet he made well if my view is that's
really a breach of contract that's
really a breach of equitable duties and
obligations but the court saw oh
Congress is saying section 230 means I'm
not supposed to allow Twitter to ever be
sued for anything that's what's happened
and that's why Congress needs to fix
that side of the equation because
unfortunately the courts haven't stepped
up to do it themselves do you think
there's an interesting piece of this
that is just because of anonymous
accounts and I don't know what the legal
protections or non protections would be
around that
if you generally look at what's
happening online if you if we removed
anonymous accounts and by the way as a
free speech guy I'm not for that because
I understand off many times many times I
mean I see this with people that I meet
at live events they'll come up to me
after and they say you know I have an
anonymous account because I'm a
conservative and I don't you know so
it's not that there there's rules it's
not that they're flame claiming people
or whatever else it is but there's a
piece of me that thanks man if you just
removed anonymous accounts and and put
put aside the decent human part of it
for a second sure but actually 80 to 90%
of all of this nonsense would disappear
because you've got brave keyboard
warriors with no skin in the game that
are trying to sow havoc I don't know if
there's a legal piece of this somewhere
there's a legal way to do it so if
you're in operating on an anonymous
account and you're doing something
that's not protected by the First
Amendment like stalking like harassing
like a like invading someone's privacy
which is a broad tort that covers a wide
range of remedies including like in the
Covington Pei case they'll bring the
first case that establishes that doxxing
is in fact an invasion of privacy so you
can sue you can require the Twitter or
Google whoever did it Facebook identify
that individual and and consequently
that individual can be held legally
liable for their course of conduct so
people who think they can hide they can
do bad things behind anonymity you're
wrong they can do good things behind
anonymity in the First Amendment
encompasses that anonymity is often
critical to all kinds of free speech but
if what you're doing is always been
outside the scope of the First Amendment
like stalking like harassing like
intending to censor and shame people
based on lies and libels you can be held
individually liable and your anonymity
of your account will not protect you
from legal responsibility it's so
interesting because I'm hearing you on
all this and then there is this other
there's the absolutist part of me on
speech yeah that even though I know we
need these protections more than ever
there's just this little piece of me
that's like I don't want everything to
get caught up in legalese right and that
and I guess that ultimately is the
balance that guys like you have to deal
with every day absolutely it was the
pitch that we made to Senator Holly was
don't treat these as utilities and start
to regulate them I understand why people
are calling for that because what
they're seeing is monopoly power mm-hmm
the interesting thing is in the First
Amendment including in California
and it used to be the law and it still
is the law in some places which is if
you have the effect of a corporate
monopoly on the public square you were
then considered a state actor for First
Amendment purposes this was established
way back because you had company towns
who are like well how do we suppress
this union movement well why don't we
just own the whole town
we only sheriff we only copied on the
public square now we'll ban petitioning
now we'll ban circulating now we'll ban
organized so by that definition you you
would argue the social media companies
are absolutely okay that's called the
Pruneyard doctor here in the state of
California which applies to private
malls not malls can't ban you from
circulating certain things in the public
spaces of those private malls well is
there anymore monopolized public square
than big tech media then Twitter then
Facebook then YouTube then Google they
own they own 85 to 95 percent of the
public square and all corporations are
creations of the state and they get
certain protections for that because
they have a corporate charter they're
given certain immunities from individual
liability for participating in that
company
well I'm exchanged for that once they
get to the place where they monopolize
the public square those two things exist
both monopolies and the public square
which is usually over 75 80 percent
control of a market space when they have
that and when it's the public square I
think they should be held to the same
First Amendment standards as everyone
else because otherwise we create this
huge loophole in the First Amendment to
privatize control of the public square
so Eric Weinstein who I'm guessing
you're familiar with had a couple of
discussions with him about this and one
of the ideas that he's put forward and
my libertarian side doesn't really like
this but but I see some value in it is
that because we don't we don't have
public spaces online correct so it makes
everything so in effect everything's
private there's nothing public so the
government has nothing to do with
anything
but maybe this would be an actual good
use of the government if there were
platforms that were government platforms
that the only rule basically was you
can't break the laws of the United
States so that people could get their
information out there but you but if you
break the laws of the United States
you're in trouble then the private
companies could do whatever the hell
they wanted and we'd have no reason to
we'd have no ability to stop them but in
effect because everything is private
there's nothing public anymore right
exactly and so my view is that once you
become a monopoly and particularly you
become a monopoly
based on federal congressional immunity
then you have different obligations than
any other private actor so that's one
argument so one argument is if you
become if you become a man if you choose
to have a monopoly in the public square
space you're gonna have the same First
Amendment rules as any government actor
that's one option
another option is just to condition
their continued immunity on First
Amendment inclusion those are the
argument that I've made to the Twitter
lawyers in the Johnson case I was like
look you guys don't have to reinvent the
wheel like oh they said they were
worried about stalking and harassing and
it's like very simple just take all the
First Amendment rules that already exist
incorporate them within your Terms of
Service mhm and then you'll eliminate
90% of your concerns and questions and
you won't have to deal with a lot of the
nonsense right well yeah like right now
their rules would be considered void for
vagueness if they were saying because
you have rules that are subject to
individual women discretion and they're
intentionally written that way right so
I mean I did you catch any of Tim Poole
and Joe Rogan with Jack exactly yeah and
he detailed this instance after instance
after instance I mean the way they
decided to de platform Alex Jones was
highly subjective very interpretive and
I've seen far worse conduct only for
example the covington case you had a
prominent Hollywood figure show an image
of saying the ha saying the covington
kid should have to go through a shredder
yeah and be killed you had raised as
long calling from the be punched in the
face yeah nothing was done about that
and yet Alex Jones post something that's
just a funny video and they're like oh
my goodness we have to get rid of Alex
job okay so I want to spend a whole
bunch of time on covington because I
think actually that was the moment that
this shifted and and maybe at a legal
sense it crystallized in my mind a
little bit more that's actually when I
reached out to you sure because I saw
you just going for it going for it and I
thought okay this is a conversation we
have to have but let's let's talk about
Jones for a minute so Jones
so you've you've done some defense work
with Jones yes I'm representing Alex
Jones and Infowars and now his outside
general counsel on all these legal
matter so you represent him across the
board on all of these things so I guess
my first question is what's it like when
Alex Jones knocks on your door or calls
you up it was a very animated guy very
nice guy very open very sincere what was
fascinating is from the get-go he was
saying 90% of what they're saying about
me isn't isn't the case he's like I
would defend this on free speech and
free press grounds anyway but what their
acts
saying I said I didn't say I never
attacked these families I never went
after these family never told people to
go to the family's homes none of that
yeah this is that stuff specific he's
about the Sandy Hook exact the Sandy
Hook case and so that there they took a
Media Matters video and assumed that's
what I said and it wasn't really
they took most of that out of context
and didn't put in that I had corrected
the record a long time ago and so part
of it was you know very nice guy
actually very friendly guy very
accessible guy even more so than Snipes
he gets mobbed when he goes out in
public with people hunting selfies and
that sort of thing and he doesn't act
like the Jaguar did with the lady
friendly so the runs at you know nice
small business enterprise you know
access TV to talk radio to Internet and
he's intended to be the poster boy of
their D platforming campaigns they want
to told the press as this case really
isn't about Alex Jones it's about the
ability of the independent press to
operate will law fair be discriminately
or disparately used against ordinary
individuals in the same way that the
platforming is happening already in the
big tech space and so are we going to
protect the little guy or not and Alex
Jones they figured would be the
convenient they would sort of create a
parody of them a caricature of them that
they could get the public to believe
make them make the audience feel bad if
they watch him mmm they may feel guilty
to be associated or attacks with him and
as soon as my representation was
announced in another lawyer norm
paddocks big old-school civil rights
lawyer in Connecticut I think he still
has a ponytail he's old-school yeah he
had friends and family members that are
connected to what happened at Sandy Hook
so he immediately wanted to involved in
the case as soon as he was Huffington
Post writes a hit piece on they don't
talk about a civil rights legacy they
don't talk about any of that it's entire
the whole thing is intended to smear him
and it's sending a message that if
you're a lawyer and you dare defend Alex
Jones we're gonna try to destroy your
reputation in the public space and
that's exactly the problem that needs to
be fixed and remedied yeah so related to
Jones specifically I mean one of the
things that I thought was was most
incredible I forget the exact order of
it but basically within 48 hours all the
platforms took him down yes and it's
like okay is that is that that you guys
truly you're calling each other and
coordinating it or is it that you're all
sort of cowards you somebody breaks the
ice and now you're just followers and I
don't know that it matters either way
right Apollo doesn't matter either way
but what I thought was okay
it doesn't even matter what he has said
short of breaking an American law in my
opinion the real issue here is that if
he can't be on there then why is
Farrakhan on there I'm not even I'm not
making a comparison direct comparison
then why is Hamas on there we could do
it zillion other things you know the
disparity is obvious in evidence there
are people who've said far worse things
that just happen to have a different
ideological intellectual perspective
even if you took all the accusations
against them at face value and 90% of
them are not true the what and that's
your typical smear campaign the
conservative or the person on the right
or the person some on the independent
anti-war left will often be attacked and
smeared 90% of what said about them is
not true but even if it was true what
the other side has said is usually far
worse and far more egregious and far
more excessive and it's the obvious
disparate treatment they're using there
they're concentrated power to and and
including their lawfare power to
effectively wipe out the little guy so
that only the big guys voice is heard
and often it's about the audience
because that one job is still gonna talk
it's just can the audience here so it's
about their right to choose their right
to choose what news they want to look at
what views they want to have well how
they filter information obviously like
like I don't represent people that are
accused of racism or the rest people
their actual racist not everybody these
days everybody right well being accused
and being a traitor but people who are
really involved in some of generally
avoid representation of them the because
I just don't wanna be affiliate just
because that there's an old personal
issue but if you look at what those boys
said let those people debate because if
you watch Richard Spencer debate
somebody else ninety-nine percent of the
time the nice come reasonable person is
not going to say Richard Spencer is
right so always expose ideas to more
ideas more sunshine because let the
ideas get let trust the audience that's
really what they're all saying all what
big tech is doing what these big
lawsuits are doing against little guys
is intended to say we don't trust the
audience to make up their own mind we
don't trust the audience to make up
their own decisions we have to control
what you think we have to control what
you do because you might choose
something that we don't want you to do
if you actually have freedom of choice
freedom of thought freedom of expression
do you think lawsuits are the answer to
stop some of this stuff I'm also
realizing right now
that we are run way to fix this is
becoming perilously short like we're
getting to the abyss pretty damn quick
the 2020 election is right around the
corner and that seems to me to be what
this is all ramping up to absolutely the
Covington case was such a glaring
example of that so I was on vacation in
Mexico yeah okay so let's just go all
inter Covington right now yeah so it was
a little town north of the port of our
outdoors is hanging out just you know
going through Twitter and I poor son of
a [ __ ] on Twitter on vacation let's see
what happens yeah so I see Maggie
Haberman the premiere reporter for the
premiere news publication in the country
covering American pilot New York Times
yeah exactly
basically calling for the expulsion of a
bunch of kids that she's never met that
she doesn't know based on an event she
didn't see and I found that so shocking
I was like we're crossing a whole new
line now if we're gonna go it's one
thing to go after what somebody said ten
years ago that's problematic on its own
terms we'll get to that in a little bit
- yeah that's what we have set you to
limitations for but the is that you're
not gonna be held responsible for what
you did when you're 10 but the or when
you're 20 when you're 40 but the here
these kids were we're just going up to
DC to be part of the pro-life March and
usually the pro-life March have I've had
family participated in that there
they're just having fun you know they're
not mean they're not out there harassing
people they're just expressing what they
believe these kids are having fun
probably the first time ever to
Washington DC there by the Lincoln
Memorial was beautiful memorial and all
of a sudden they start getting harassed
out of the blue and they have likely
never met the black Hebrew Israelites
right some of us that have know what's
coming ivory I lived in New York City
for many years by these guys many times
every insult known to man and like
really what they're almost like an
insult comic dreams
yeah they find something going next than
the next thing the next are like bad Don
Rickles exactly yeah the worst version
yeah right so you combined Farrakhan
with Don room yeah right so but these
kids have no idea yeah and they have an
african-american friend that's there
with them and then he's being attacked
and so they start defending him they
start a tag and making various anti-gay
slurs there they they question they
respond back to that in defense of
people who are gay yeah so it's like
these are not mean kids these are kids
trying to handle a shocking environment
they decide to go in turn
and start okay let's not deal with these
guys let's start do our school tears one
of their school tears is the old haiku
as the haiku dance which is the great
New Zealand rugby team on blackjack I in
fact two weeks before it's shown it to
my son
it sounds like look at how awesome
there's oh it's awesome it's a hole over
YouTube by the way anyone can watch it
and absolutely it so when I first saw it
in the movie with Matt Damon yeah yeah
that's a greatest sports dance I've ever
seen yeah so the in fact before if I
want to get inspired by something I'll
just put it on go get ready yeah so the
so they do that as part of it that's why
when the kids turn it's closed off and
it's right after that's happening then
all of a sudden a Native American comes
up with some friends and he's doing the
drums so two-thirds of the kids think oh
he's joining in because we just did the
Haiku thing oh this is great and what do
they know the most popular Native
American sports thing they know is
there's a tomahawk Chuck yeah from from
the Florida State from Kansas City
Chiefs Indian all the places where
they're familiar in there it's right on
the on the border of the Kentucky Ohio
border so the kind of programs they'd be
familiar with that's what they see not
nobody's mocking him nobody's chanting
build the wall out of nobody's blocking
him nobody's surrounding him and then at
one point they started some of the kids
art to figure out okay something's odd
because some of the people behind him
are saying go back to Europe and where
did that come from
and then they realized something's weird
then they just leave and then as they're
on their bus home all of a sudden their
lives are being upended and they're not
being upended by just some random body
counts who started they're being upended
by Kathy Griffin who's calling for them
to be doxed they're upended by Maggie
haver been calling for them to be
expelled they're upended by Matthew Dowd
who's on ABC who's was a prominent
Catholic on ABC saying bad things need
to happen to these kids and a navarro
who's saying bad things need to happen
to these kids
almost the entire media and then you
have Hollywood celebrities calling for
them to be put through the shredder for
them to be attacked for them to be you
had a writer who claimed to be part of
Saturday at night live stations gonna
extend sexual favors for anybody who
physically assaulted these people and I
was like these are private kids these
are by the way these are blue check
verified people these are not fake
account people's Twitter yet is you
should pay attention to that we've
verified that we've validated that we've
authenticated that we've authorized and
twittered social media does almost
nothing about this
in fact they run with the fake news
story and these
kids lives are almost over in five
seconds based on a misleading video and
so I saw it and I when I first saw the
videos like oh that's gonna be fake news
story just cuz you know DC politics you
know you know lefty protest culture you
know the chances that a bunch of
Catholic kids came up and found a lefty
to harass is not real high in watch DC
it said it happened in a small town in
Alabama okay maybe but there's like this
story doesn't make sense
yeah and so I was like okay that will
probably blow over and that was well as
getting on a plane to go to bucerias
then I get to post and see these things
and I'm like they're gonna destroy these
kids lives and I realize if they think
if they can do this they can do anything
to anyone at anytime anywhere and that's
exactly so then you started tweeting
about it alongside a couple of other
people and I thought a couple other
people in the legal world yeah and I
thought all right I've got to talk to
this guy because if this one doesn't get
corrected which fortunately thanks to
you and it's ongoing you and several
other people it is getting corrected
right if I thought if this one doesn't
get corrected if we let them demolish
high school students we're done exactly
we are done so can you catch us up on
sort of where where this is all at now
so what I did initially is I first is
proud of tweet I said if anybody wants
to sue Maggie Haberman now represent for
free and I was just adjutant you know
that ticked off and and tuned into
Twitter it's like two days later when I
came back and all of a sudden it blown
up and I'm getting all these inquiries
and I'm like okay I realized that this
is becoming very high-profile and so I
go in Fox and my goal is to get
everybody to start to retract start to
back up start to retell the different
story and a lot unfortunate ly almost
all the institutional media starts to
backtrack fast so to be clear you did
not want to go the legal route actually
you were given everybody man I saw you
do this you gave them the chance guys
just delete the tweets did you even ask
them to issue apologies I don't even
remember what I said was I said that
ever he's got 48 hours to do one of
three things yeah either correct or
delete or apologize just do something to
correct the record mm-hmm and don't eat
or credit Congresswoman Omar who usually
has no problem saying anything under
God's green earth
she did she did it within an hour but
she only did it because roll call
covered my story right so his roll call
covered my stories like oh maybe I can
get sued and went you know took it down
yeah and by the way right before that
she had sent out a tweet linking them to
white supremacists and a whole bunch of
it
false information she libel demand hold
me new unique ways yeah I'll leave it to
her to figure out a way to do that yeah
the this is a member of Congress by the
way yeah you have senator Warren who's
running for the presidency of the United
States repeating false statements about
the East Cape well that's because she's
Native American yeah yes yes exactly yes
stand up for her truck yeah the like
they portrayed him as a Native American
elder well I clerked for Native American
tribes I worked for one of these
old-school lefty one of the best trial
lawyers in the country and I was like I
was like I don't think he's an elder of
that particular tribe then I realized
they were just confusing the terms
because he's elderly they were gonna
call him an elder I was like that's an
insult to old men most Native American
elders are very carefully selected they
take their job very seriously in fact
their court system if we had an ideal
court system in the world it would be
the Native American elder system I'd be
all for it because there's 12 12 people
sit around and you come in you tell me
your dispute and they try to find a
remedy that will satisfy everybody and
they try not to be too punitive they try
not to be too too involved they just try
to say okay what's causing this problem
how can we address the cause of it and
and their focus on a reconciliation how
can we bring people together so it
doesn't happen again and people don't
feel bad at the end of it not great for
your profession but much better system
I'd be all for it I mean happy happily
forfeit my law degree to see that system
put in place have the 12 members of your
community yet to decide these kind of
disputes and find ways to put people
back together and protect all the things
that matter to us rather than deepening
the division and the bitterness that
exists and the legal system often
creates that people often leave it even
when they win unsatisfied and so the so
but so they put this guy in that context
just like he wasn't a Vietnam War
veteran the was really not really being
accurate they're trying to script a
narrative trying to tell a story but
doing it to these kids and include the
message was if we can destroy them we
can destroy you
it was an ultimate exemplar mechanism of
media narrative structuring and that's
why I volunteered helped them out and so
now represent 14 families in Covington
oh about 90% of the people I went on Fox
and said 48 hours notice just clean it
up and we'll be done
and even after that have given people
additional opportunities and additional
opportunities please take it down please
correct that none of the family members
want to sue they don't want to deal with
the nightmares of the legal system they
don't have to go through all that hassle
or Atal
but they want the record corrected and
they don't want to happen to anyone else
that's it and so I was like let's set a
record let's set a pattern let's at a
precedent ear that this can get
corrected and remedied that you can't do
this to these kids you can't do this to
these people that you do have standards
you have to be bound by those standards
you have to be governed by those
standards and you have to act according
to those standards for those that refuse
to do anything about it they're gonna be
sued yeah so some of them still left the
tweets up or didn't apologize
Griffin Matthew Dowd oddly enough Maggie
Haberman senator Warren congresswoman
Holland those are the five highest
profile examples of people who refuse to
correct when you see a mob descend it's
a little it's a little hard to figure
out how coordinated it is whether it's
groupthink is this coming from the top
is this organic as much as you've had to
deal with these things and especially
since you dealt with the most recent one
that's still unfolding right now what's
your take is it a little bit of
everything it's two different things one
is they're starting to green-light mob
culture that's what was scary here
because this started out with a bot
account who was spreading it through
sort of liberal ideological culture who
was trying to create an online mob but
the reality is that online mob would
have never reached critical mass at
least as related to these kids without
the blue checkmark crowd saying yeah
yeah yeah mm-hmm and that's the problem
there the greenlight for online mob
behavior and that's why they have to be
stopped and then they have to correct
their actions or they have to be
remedied in court because they are the
ones that are permitting it and
expanding it and for them I don't know
how often it's deliberate and how often
so cultural mindset I used to call it
cotton ball culture so in the South
people used to go to the cotton ball
they're part of the privileged classes
when they're 16 and 17 and they're sort
of in court incorporated IDI
acculturated to a certain mindset so
it's not that they'll get together and
conspire but that they have a certain
point of view that's that's been created
by this culture they share mm-hmm and I
think there's some of them online mob
culture that's been festering over the
past half decade decade and the worst
part of it is it continued to be
greenlight by institutional people or
people with big platforms and big power
are you shocked also how the racial
element has become so blatant so we
was like these kids are white so you
know they have punchable faces or or
excusing the black Israelites just
because they're black so they can call
these kids [ __ ] and that's okay even
though you're supposed to defend gay
people but I guess if it's black people
you know they create this oppression a
little intersectional yeah this
intersexual lunacy so are you just
shocked how how solidified that is in so
many people's brains
it's extraordinary for like two
different reasons when whenever I see
people do it or raise it my instinctual
view is it was like well what does that
person actually done for civil rights
so like when I've been attacked I'm like
well I've done civil rights for 20 years
I've done very difficult cases in very
difficult places advocating for civil
rights so I was like is this for a
person really out there trying to help
protect people or is it somebody who
wants a social brownie point in social
prestige point for being on the right
political side mmm
and that's 95 percent of these are
people that aren't actually doing
anything to improve the well-being of
African Americans and Latinos in this
country the second part of it is it's
become social prestige to out people
that are op that over a particular
disfavored political class and it
happens to be that right now are
disfavored political classes are my
people our men are people of certain
sort of parts of the country certain
political orientation kids wearing mega
hats exactly I was like that's the same
sort of bigotry the bigotry doesn't know
color bigotry is bigotry and this is
just racial bigotry disguised as as
trying to protect people they're not out
to protect people they're out to hurt
and harm people and they just want to
feel morally justified when they do it
so when you now have to have to move
forward on this lawsuit that you're
saying you're going into not really
because you want to you're giving these
people a chance to go out how does this
even work logistical II when you're
going after people that have nothing to
do with each other other than they all
did it on the same platform so we're
gonna bring it as a class claim so all
the plaintiffs will be combined so all
14 kids will be one group of plaintiffs
and all the defendants will be combined
so the so you can combine the defendants
together when there's a common nucleus
of facts and they're behaving in a
coordinated way even if it doesn't rise
to the level state legal conspiracy or
aiding and abetting which it may in some
of these instances the effect of it is
you can add them together because for
judicial economy purposes they're all
part of the same event and it's easier
for one judge to preside over all the
cases combined than the cases
differently and so it's interesting some
of the left medias client use use of
these kind of defamation claims has done
use this exact procedure and it's time
to use the exact procedure back the
other way you gotta be careful what you
wish for exactly so let's talk a little
bit about what's going on with Tucker
Carlson right now Tucker's been on this
show I go on his show every couple weeks
I find him to be a decent guy we have
political disagreements that we have
expressed to each other publicly before
but I think he's on the right side
especially when it comes to the free
speech stuff oh now media matters which
you mentioned already there they're
going after him they're finding old
audio clips on a shock jock Bubba what's
his name Bubba Bubba Gump Bubba Bubba
Bubba that's something but yeah whatever
it is but in effect a Howard Stern like
figure exactly where I was thinking I
tweeted something the other day that I
wish Howard Stern was maybe a little
more engaged these days than he is I
don't begrudge him he's living through a
lot and he's happy he's been a great
fighter on our side of the free-speech
thing but it's like if he was to take
the 30 years of stuff that politicians
actors comedians authors musicians
everybody has said the crazy sexual acts
that have been done in that see all
those things and said you know what this
is all part of life right all say things
we get in atmospheres where you joke
differently this way then you would that
way all of these things like I would
love to help have him aiding us right
now in this fight oh great
so that's just one piece but putting
that aside Media Matters is now digging
into old things of Tucker's and you know
apparently he said [ __ ] there were a
couple other things and they're trying
to make it sound like he's racist and
he's for abusing kids and all of these
things yeah and I wonder what his legal
recourse is now he's not apologizing
that that's one thing which I think
that's pretty good for the if you're
gonna stand against the mob don't
apologize yeah but also if their because
their goal is just to destroy this man
their goal is in some sort of legal
justice right their goal is and their
goal isn't to help anyone
exactly right there's doing something
that I can't figure out their goal is to
destroy a man and if you can destroy a
man you can destroy an idea and you can
get all sorts of other people to shut up
so nicely what the hell do we do it's
very much a censorship shaming campaign
designed to marginalize his audience and
marginalize him from having access to
his audience and to be an example to
future people so that they won't hey you
better not come after big tech which is
really what distinguishes Tucker from
anyone else on Fox or anyone else in the
political conservative space he's
probably the lead high profile person
taking on big tech in this country one
of the leading guys saying I think
you're telling me I should have you on
retainer is that it's a systemic its
institutional it's and its deliberate
and it's obvious so like I first got
familiar with this aspect of it in the
context of representing Alex Jones
because I was trying to figure out why
do people think he said a bunch of stuff
that he actually didn't say or did
things that he actually didn't do or
think 90% of what he said was this as
opposed to that and then it found out
watching Joe Rogan that it was actually
a Media Matters thing that Joe wrote
himself watch he's like oh no I saw this
Media Matters thing is like who would
trust Media Matters like they they're
politically motivated their partisan
oriented they take various forms of like
people complain about secret corporate
cash and dark money Media Matters has
tons of secret corporate cash and why is
that is that a big problem right here
that the nonprofit's now are probably I
don't know all the laws related to
nonprofits but they're probably in
almost every political case stepping
beyond their boundaries they definitely
are and then what's happening is they're
becoming clearly their partisan
organizations so here nobody would think
Media Matters is nonpartisan I'm pretty
sure they didn't go after joy read on
cable news when her whole size down
about the anti-gay blog post they
defended all kinds of people on the Left
have said all far worse things and at
least are politically ideologically
aligned with the left are supposed to be
in the first instance and this is the
left set of standards that's something
you say 20 years ago somehow means you
can never have a public platform ever
again for the rest of your human
existence this is not an American
standard this is not a conservative
standard this is very much a left
standard D but they don't apply it to
their own people ever at all I mean some
of the things Joe Biden is said over the
years yeah he's a leading Democratic
candidate for the presidency and then
that guy open his mouth and crazy stuff
came well half the things the Trump says
now although he says them sloppily are
the exact same things that Obama said
about immigration and Clinton said about
immigration and Diane finds that of the
rest of them precisely yeah
so the it's extraordinary for the for
this sort of one-sided application but
clearly Tucker is a target because
Tucker is willing to take on big tech
and the goal is there they're testing
when can we use something in the
person's past because it's extraordinary
about all of us what unites all of it
whether it's the covington case or the
alex jones case is that you have people
who are unwilling to debate ideas it's
all about if you disagree with them then
they're gonna target you as an
individual they're gonna make your life
difficult as an individual they're gonna
harass you as an individual stalk you as
an individual they've already been to
Tucker his house by the way precisely
when his wife was there and had no clue
what was going on and they're banging on
the door and that was reason why Fox
went off Twitter for an extended time
period as Twitter would do nothing about
it I mean the the extraordinary
discrepancy and disparity everybody can
witness and everybody and people like
Tim Poole was on the Left can say this
is problematic this is kind of obvious
what you guys are doing and we recognize
how problematic it is because they're
not gonna stop there it's like Alex
Jones they're not gonna stop with Alex
Jones they're gonna use it as an example
to try to go after everyone else to
scare and intimidate it everyone else
you better not be in the independent
press you better not be in the
independent speech you better not be
sharing a dissonant narrative or we're
going to be able to de monetize you D
platform you d Bank you BL or defame you
routinely and regularly and get away
with and that's why we need to equalize
the playing field and but for Tucker's
case what he could do is he could
potentially go after Media Matters for
misrepresenting and mischaracterizing
the set of events they have a habit of
putting on a video that D contextualizes
what happened they did Alex Jones they
would take them where he's talking about
this subject put into a minute where it
looks like he's talking with Sandy Hook
he's actually not he's talking about
something else and they would say these
are all the statements so Mike they've
likely done the same thing to him right
there's limited remedies I also saw one
of I think it was one of the directors
of Media Matters I actually retweeted it
saying if you think this is bad we've
got a lot more something to that effect
and I thought this they're they're
telling you how evil they are because
they're saying we are releasing this
information in a calculated way to
destroy a man we're not just we're not
just doing it for publicly like we found
all this stuff and we're just gonna put
it all out there on day one
because people should know about his
past it's like we're gonna keep the
monster being fed so that it can keep
feeding on correct it's why are they so
scared of ideas if they think Tucker's
wrong than ideas debate his ideas why
attack him why especially why attack him
on something he said 20 years ago on a
shock jock show there's also something
crazy you could do you could actually
pick up the remote you're not gonna
believe this
there's a button on that thing that
allows you to scroll up or down have you
seen this thing exactly I mean if you
don't like what you're hearing you don't
have to listen to it if you think it's
wrong you should engage it years ago
professor lash great historian passed
away some years ago he said the reason
why we expose our ideas and debate other
people isn't necessarily to persuade
them it's because they're going to
expose ideas that there are weaknesses
in our own argument and we often
research a topic when somebody says well
that must be wrong and we go and find
out about it we become more informed by
engaging in the public debate process
and that's that's good that's healthy
but these are people who fundamentally
don't believe in free thought free
expression and free speech fundamentally
they believe that you should have the
right thought not that you should have
free thought you should have the right
expression not that you should have free
expression they've combined sort of the
inquisitional Catholic Church with like
1920s communists and they've integrated
the two in their approach and they're
using our legal system and using our
political system and their superior
power and the cultural areas of
influence whether it's Hollywood whether
it's big media whether it's big tech to
suppress and oppress those people who
have different or dissonant views than
them including people on parts of the
left so but me people like Tim Poole is
being called a Nazi right because he
appears on Joe Rogan and ask a few
questions of Twitter yeah I mean this is
insanity so that's actually I was gonna
go somewhere else but let's jump there
for a second so like for example when I
had Tim Poole on last week there were
verified people on Twitter calling Tim a
Nazi and Mia fascists or me and Nazi and
Tim a fascist I I've mentioned this
before I've had I grew up around
Holocaust survivors I lost family on
both my mom and my dad's side now again
I'm the free speech guy so I don't want
to sue these people but is there some
legal remedy for this if I was someone
different than I am
correct yes there is because for example
I took a couple years ago the cassandra
fairbanks case he gets have a roller
mm-hmm and one of the reasons I took it
is I was and reformer lefty by the way
she's now all Trump but former lefty I
drink so there one night she gave me her
full on lefty lefty lefty lefty yeah
exactly part Porto Rican yeah and she
was accused by Emma roller flashing a
white power gesture and this was the
universal location others became a white
power I was like so and so she was on
Twitter she's like I gotta stop this can
somebody help me
I said I'll help for free cuz I like the
area of the case and thought needed to
stop this because they're used to being
able to say I'll call someone a Nazi
I'll call someone a racist and that's
not actionable at law and I wanted to
change that I wanted to say when you
make very specific statements about
someone's belief structure that someone
can interpret and a jury can objectively
verify as either true or false then I
think that should be something you can
sue over so I brought the case in DC and
we couldn't meet the actual malice
standard but the court said yes saying
someone is a racist in a particular way
like saying it's a white power gesture
you can be sued for the United States
for libel and lies and under the
defamation laws of DC which are more
restrictive than a lot of other laws so
that's established the standard that all
these people think I can just say
anything and never get sued that's we're
gonna make the point the covington case
no you can't yeah if you say things that
you know not to be true that a jury can
look at and say I can objectively verify
this we the juries make determinations
about whether someone is involved in a
hate crime everyday they made
determinations whether someone has
racially discriminatory animus or
motivation every day
so if they're good if someone's accusing
you of being a racist that should be
actionable in law because a jury can
make that determination as a matter of
objective fact and the Fairbanks case
establishes precedent that you can under
certain circumstances get legal remedy
for that guy it's it will never cease to
amaze me that the free speech crew are
the people that have to do certain
things through law exact such just to
maintain free speech which aside it
sounds so counterintuitive but it's yes
so fascinated me so a couple times
you've mentioned Fox yeah I think
there's something interesting happening
here
now has CNN or MSNBC ever put you on no
have they ever asked you to come on CNN
did way back about two years ago okay so
CNN into
years ago MSNBC has not Fox puts you on
right now Fox only puts me on and they
put me on with no I'd go on live shows
they don't tell me to say anything I
don't say whatever the hell I want to
say I often bring up liberal cred while
while I'm on there yeah
but it seems also clear to me that
partly what's going on with the Tucker
thing is that they are really going for
fox there the plan is alright we'll take
out Tucker he's sort of the bravest or
the most outspoken or whatever it is but
really then we'll make this about going
for Fox's licensing and broadcast
abilities and and everything else you're
nodding so I suspect you agree with me
but I I'm amazed because it's like there
is so much lefty media and you never saw
the right trying to destroy all the
lefty media there's basically one Fox
and it doesn't mean I love everything
they're doing I don't but you need some
counterbalance don't ya absolutely if
you have the approach of the
inquisitional Catholic Church or
institutional communism of a statist
variety then what drives you crazy is
the heresy so you don't look at it and
say geez how many fair balance
expressions do we have on both sides to
the inquisitional Catholic Church
there's only the Catholic Church
perspective and everybody else needs to
be burned at the stake if for the
statist communists same dynamic there's
one state channel there's no alternative
state channel there's no anti state
channel so when you come in from that
perspective what unites a alex jones the
covington case and fox is these are
three institutions and they represent
different institutions that are giving
an independent narrative so when I was
at Yale we did a history project that
was actually about why african-americans
and poor whites in the South were often
treated or portrayed in very
discriminatory ways and cultural medium
between 1997 and what you find is
historically those communities have
alternative narratives their
grandparents and parents tell stories
different than say the civics book
version they learn in 3rd grade in
public school mm-hmm and so consequently
those groups were often chained and
censored and portrayed in a negative
light so that the broader public
audience wouldn't trust them to listen
to them word or a react to them so the
same thing is here like you look at the
Covington kids they represent private
Catholic education what is private
Catholic Catholic education is one of
the last institutions of independent
thought compared to say all the public
state schools in public institutions so
it drives them crazy that they represent
this institution that they can't control
their thoughts and mind of right because
they don't have access to that it's and
then you even saw in the midst of all
this I'm sure you saw this there was
that guy from the New York Times who
said I want to know your stories
remember I forget what the hashtag he
used was but he wanted to know you're
Catholic he was like hashtag Catholic
school stories precisely because let's
now New York Times let's go after them
once we're done with this thing so let's
go after the whole Catholic Church let's
go after the Catholic schools because we
need people to be afraid to be a part of
those schools to be ashamed if they're
connected to those schools parents
worried that if them skills are listed
on their kids CV their kids futures will
be impaired and not have these schools
being independent sources of thought
outside of the sort of cultural liberal
hegemonic view and the same thing is
true like Alex Jones represents sort of
an independent part of the press a Fox
News represents in an institutional part
of the press that's independent that
expresses its own perspective that's not
part of the left majority
I mean CNN and MSNBC and ABC and NBC and
CBS even they're using public airwaves
are overwhelmingly on one side yeah same
with PBS same with NPR
and there's a lot of good value and I
watch all of them at different times
I've listened to them at different times
but I want the other side expressed and
so what it's this fear of free
expression this fear of free speech
that's leading to these censorship
campaigns these same campaigns these
targeting campaigns these privacy
invasion campaigns what I've told people
is if you're ever to the point where
you're attacking a person or trying to
shame a person trying to censor a person
trying to invade their privacy then what
you're really looking you're doing is
you're looking in the mirror and telling
yourself I've failed on the argument and
I can't persuade on ideas no audience
would actually believe my ideas so it's
an admission of failure and they're
really resorting to these extreme
tactics because they're recognizing
they're losing in the public debate do
you think part of it also is that it's
intentional not now perhaps they're
losing in the public debate I think
that's probably you could debate that
either way on one hand I'm very enthused
about sort of where we're at in this on
the other hand it's very scary too
because you see this socialist whatever
the hell that is rising so but putting
that aside do you think part of it is
that there in doing it intentionally
because they just want to basically sow
chaos all over the place that partly
what they need
for whatever their political goals are
they need this system that has been
pretty freaking spectacular for 200 plus
years to appear chaotic so they so they
what do they do they so care
it's very what's amazing is how parallel
is the 1920's street violence in europe
so you see like a lot of the communist
tactics that were used back then and the
fascist tactics that were used back then
was in well we're designed to sow
distrust in the system so distrust in
the institutions that's it protectively
that's it every day now aoc doing
another thing about how evil we are in
reagan's zbling capitalism are yeah I
think with like the combination you're
talking about where there's these bad
ideas that are spreading and yet winning
in the public debate what unites them is
if both sides get presented most people
will take a humanitarian decision will
make a good choice based on their common
experience and their common sense
whereas and so that's why this side that
wants to spread their ideas knows they
can't allow that open fair debate to
happen or those institutions to be
trusted and protected and expected if
they candy if they can get people to no
longer to not listen to not hear
independent voices to be afraid to be a
part of independent institutions to feel
ashamed if they're connected to it to
say hey if I'm a lawyer or represent
this person I'm gonna be attacked if I
if I'm in the in the public arena and I
voice an independent view I'm gonna be
targeted and harassed and softer than
the rest they want people to be scared
and intimidated to express their ideas
because I think they know that in a non
chaotic open debate structure they don't
win I think that's what they're wrecking
you because otherwise you know it's a
resort to these ridiculous tactics and
techniques if your ideas are great and
popular you don't have to use chaotic
techniques you don't have to you don't
have to try to censor people you don't
have to attack people you don't have to
say what a Tucker say 20 years ago on a
on a shock jock show you can say hey I
disagree what he said yesterday on Fox
and then willing to debate him and
Tuckers one of the few people who says
hey you can come on the show and we'll
debated that's quite literally what his
statement said if you don't like my
ideas let's talk about exactly all right
so I want to ask you something that I
think will sort of thread the oh you
know what I want to ask you one other
little tech thing and then and then
something I think it'll kind of bring us
full circle here so one of the things is
you know you see me do this all time
where I have to publicly shame YouTube
in Thai they're monetizing my video or
making sure people aren't being
unsubscribed or the rest of it then and
a certain amount of people
say but Dave your your libertarian or
whatever you're not allowed to complain
because you don't want the government
Bob which is so idiotic because of
course I'm using my voice is a citizen
that's what you're supposed to do okay
putting that aside do you think there is
some interesting legal mechanism if it
was to be found out that they were
treating traffic differently so that's a
little bit different than what we talked
about earlier was talking about content
specifically so you're saying this or
that but what if they're actually
turning the screws just based on not
something you said but they have a
general sort of a broad sense that they
don't want certain ideas getting out
there I think there are contractual
principles equitable principles and
consumer protection principles that are
in play so once you induce someone to
participate in your platform and then
you monetize their participation to me
you have contractual obligations
equitable obligations you can't have
unjust enrichment so you say hey if you
participate we these are the rules and
if as long as you abide by those rules
we'll make sure you share in the profits
for example of monetizing your
individual video and if they don't do
that if they manipulate the algorithm
they misrepresent facts they induce
conduct and then only keep the profit
for themselves or use it for a
politicized purpose that's different
than what they said those are all
consumer protection violations equitable
law violations and legal violations
sometimes recommend remedy by statute
sometimes remedy by common law well
there's no reason for big tech to be
above the law right there there might
also be some legal thing related to
their own board right I mean if they're
doing things that are not relate well if
they're not doing the most profitable
thing their board may I don't know
exactly realize all the shareholders can
take action so there could be derivative
suits by shareholders they could go to
the board but they can also bring
derivative legal claims against the
institution saying they're not promoting
the best profit they're creating undue
legal risk and liability they're not
behaving in a manner consistent with
their professional obligations and their
contractual obligations to the air
they're in own investors and so they can
also bring action and in fact the left
but a lot of people look at what the
left has done between the 70s and 2000
you'll see a lot of legal roadmaps for
how to go at what they're doing now so
they were some of the you know the on
the apartheid campaigns in South Africa
they targeted different people using
shareholder
suits using shareholder claims using
shareholder complaints to remedy that of
people who are profiting from the
apartheid system in South Africa why
can't we do the same thing now based on
the same legal theories same factual
predicates as that as what's taking
place here which is inconsistent with
their obligations and promises to people
I guess partly and this brings me to the
last question it's partly about bravery
you need citizens who are brave enough
you need lawyers who are brave enough
and they've created a system where
everyone is afraid because the when I go
out speaking to college campuses or even
I do QA what I'm doing stand-up or
wherever I go the question I get more
than anything else is I'm afraid to say
what I think and what should I do and
it's usually students that are saying I
want to get a grade because I want to
get out I want to get to grad school or
whatever and I always think it's like
man if everyone's thinking this if we
all just stopped if we all just stopped
acquiescing to it we could actually
change this thing like that so my
question to you is you and you mentioned
your father before but why why are you
willing to do this why are you willing
to put your ass on the line where does
this come from in you so it's two things
one it's it's growing up so grew up poor
in the South got a scholarship to
private schools scholarship to Yale when
I was at Yale they tried to get rid of
poor students who were there let it
protest by leaving Yale in order to get
them to reinstate their policies and I
saw there was like I'm one kid I'm 19
years old
I'm challenging all of Yale University
which wasn't exactly a small institution
and just by leaving the school and
getting public attention for it I got
them to reverse their policies and
protect poor students same access that I
had to rights to full financial aid
rights to be treated in a
non-discriminatory manner in the
application process so as I at a young
age I learned one person can change the
world when I was a real little kid I
loved Medgar Evers and Medgar Evers had
this great quote where they asked him
why he wasn't afraid to die and he said
most men die a thousand deaths every day
I'm only gonna die once and I was little
kids like I want to be a beggar Evers
it's like that is so powerful that is so
important that's so influential and you
realize one person can make a difference
and when you realize one person can make
a difference if they know it here and
act on it here then you realize that
that that's the power that's the passion
that's what leads you to want to change
the world not be afraid of I've had
rogue agents threatened me
IRS people put me under audit every
other year whenever I win a case I've
had Rogue judges threatened me I've had
people say that they're gonna try to put
me under bogus Criminal Investigation
I've had every smear campaign known to
man I've had bomb threats come in
because of my covington case
representation none of it concerns me
because if you understand that you
really have the power as one person to
make a real difference in the world then
other people will start to recognize
that and they'll act on their power
they'll voice their their abilities
they'll use their capabilities to make a
meaningful difference and that's how the
world changes and that's how the world
becomes a better place that is how you
end an interview can we smoke one of
those cigars you brought here all right
we're done here follow Robert I have a
feeling you'll be back here yeah I have
a feeling that's gonna happen on Twitter
at Barnes underscore law
[Music]